happening right now here at five a group
is holding an event tonight to protest
one henderson school return to distance
learning lamping elementary transitioned
back to learning online this week citing
a high number of cobit 19 cases on
campus and now some parents starting to
push back
sasha loftus joining us now live there
tonight with more sasha
denise you can already see quite a few
people here behind me as this protest
just got underway here at lamping
elementary in henderson now as you
mentioned the school transitioned to
distance learning earlier this week due
to a high number of covet 19 case
numbers on campus those here today are
protesting that decision they want their
kids to continue learning in person the
school's principal released a statement
earlier this week saying the school
would return to distance learning for
about two weeks as leaders assessed the
high number of coveted cases again on
campus here he said at this time
students not showing covid's symptoms
should be able to return to in-person
learning on august 30th now clark county
school district returned to in-person
learning earlier this month lamping is
the first to go back to distance
education again for this two weeks the
district tells eight news now it does
work closely with the health district
and decisions like this are on a school
by school basis now again this protest
just started just a couple people here
right now you can see them with signs
there are some children here and parents
as well we will of course have the
latest talk to people out here get their
side of things that's coming up here
tonight at six o'clock on 8 news now for
now reporting live in henderson sasha
loftis 8 news now